will her intermittent fasting create a
piece that's lasting yes Cynthia's got a
hunch she can stop War by skipping lunch
actress Cynthia Nixon started a 48-hour
hunger strike on Monday demanding a
permanent ceasefire of the Israel Hamas
War wow two whole days without eating
cat could do that standing on her
head but it kind of defeats the point of
striking if you announce ahead of time
when you'll
stop this has less credibility than
Dylan mulany selling
tampons it's true I love this audience
it's less of a hunger strike and more of
a look at me I used to have a job
rally if you're having trouble
remembering Nixon she played Miranda on
something called Sex in the City not to
be confused with sex in the the city
shelters the Michael Loftus
[Laughter]
story amazing you call him friend you
call this little Leprechaun evil man
friend anyway Cynthia and her pal
started their Cal calorically challenged
protest outside the White House calling
on Biden to order immediate end to the
conflict you know because Islamic
terrorists always do what the president
of the United States tells them to do
right the rest of the protesters are
taking part in a five-day fast but
Cynthia bailed after two prompting
prompting a Hamas spokesman to say
that's such a Miranda
move yeah strike has ended by now and
the war goes on too bad if she really
wanted to see results she wouldn't
threatened to go on a hunger strike she
threatened to make another Sex in the
City movie am I right
cat oh those movies were so I don't know
cheesy and melodramatic I only watched
them like three or four times
yeah oh is there a question or aren't
all there's often not so aren't all
actresses in Hollywood on a hunger
strike yeah well look I I think it's I
also feel for you know innocent people
who are suffering who being killed
anywhere in the world I also like this
kind of protest because it's peaceful
and also doesn't cause any traffic yeah
that's true but I'm not sure that the
celebrity power here actually has any
power cuz I don't feel like Hamas and
Sex in the City have any crossover
appeal in terms of their fan base
exactly I don't think terrorists are
walking around like I'm such a
Miranda I don't think I don't think so I
don't think be fans of the show what's
the name of the main character Carri
Carri car I like how you pretend like
you didn't know she she's so stressed
out all the time because she has to
write one column a week yeah exactly she
has to write one column a week she's
like and her voiceover for this was and
then I finally realized that Hamas
wouldn't listen to
[Laughter]
us is the idiocy that they thought they
would have an impact listen uh I think I
almost did the same thing
yeah two day fast yeah wow exactly
exactly and just you think well our the
White House probably would be like my
God what do we do yeah you
know what do we
do I'm beginning to think that you know
what I'm beginning to think that this
was timed with a
colonoscopy but I'm just saying 48
listen
Greg these aren't these aren't even
protests Dick Gregory went on a hunger
strike for like four years like yes he
lived off water and being pissed off you
know what I'm saying like you don't come
out and say I'm going on a fast for 48
hours which by the way means you're
going to eat at some point during the
day yeah intermittent fasting means you
eat for four hours and the rest of the
day you don't yeah
so so I yeah Michael serious question is
a hunger strike an appropriation of your
hobo culture
it really
is when me and the boys go miles and
miles and days for days without cooking
because there not a symbol of a cat
which means a nice lady lives here uh
yeah this is uh this is horrible
although I do want a smash cut to a
group of terrorists watching Sex in the
City right now yeah you know like oh she
broke up with Mr
big one of them blows
up but Cynthia like I've seen chicks
fast longer when they have to slip into
an ugly bridesmaid's dress it's true
right and to say that she's doing this
for Gaza you know and like next she's
probably going to get like you know a
face lift to end the war in Ukraine and
then I'm going to get some lipo suction
for the children of the Amazon and and
then a Brazilian for
Brazil it's all for the others you know
I love you know I love the world because
my silk soft skin and Youthful
glue Emily but she wants
peace that's the point you're going to
fast for two days live in a
sorority be an NFL cheerleader you'll be
fasting for years this is so abject
nonsense and the irony to me too other
than the this the ridiculous celebrity
aspect of this is that this person
remember ran for governor yeah of New
York state so we have someone who's
who's holding a sign talking about 6,000
children in Gaza but you would think
running for governor what about the
182,000 kids that are missing in the US
because of Goda ways what about the
thousands of young girls raped on their
way to the southern border that's
totally open thanks to her favorite
person Biden there are so many thousands
and hundreds of thousands of children
right now in plights that are so
horrible equally those 6,000 but the
point remains that this is what she's
virt signaling about and she honestly
thought she had the chops to be a
politician here I mean I guess she does
cuz she's an but the point
remains she is so underqualified and
what she has to say is such absolute BS
and she unfortunately is taking the mic
away from all of those people who voices
actually matter right all right watch
the language Emily no hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will will not get it anywhere
else